c'est le rassemblement national
aujourd'hui qui progresse dans les
campagnes et pas euh les écologistes
est-ce que vous avez raté quelque chose
écoutez probablement probablement mais
je pense que c'est surtout euh ça fait
40 ans qu'on rate quelque chose avec
l'agriculteur avec la on a un modèle qui
aujourd'hui est profondément
inégalitaire 80 % des aides de la
politique agricole commune donc 80 % euh
des premier budget européens vont vers
20 % des agriculteurs les plus
importants le système de la politique
agricole commun parce qu'il faut faut
expliquer aux téléspectatrices aux
téléspectateurs c'est plus vous
produisez plus vous avez d'hctard plus
vous touchez et donc dans ce monde
aujourd'hui très instable explosion du
coup des intrants marché internationaux
très instables libéralisme libre échange
dans ce monde-là vous avez le le le le
le piège qui a été tendu et construit
aussi malheureusement par la FNSEA c'est
de dire au fond c'est ce que certains
paysan appelleent le cannibalisme
agricole c'estàdire qu'en fait vous ne
pouvez survivre
quen prenant le le le le le la la ferme
d'à côté qui est en train de s'écrouler
les petits disparaissent 27 fermes par
jour disparaissent et ça c'est la
responsabilité de la FNSEA le principal
syndicat agricoleû la politique agricole
française est construite depuis 40 ans
entre les gouvernements de gauche et de
droite et la FNSA la politique agricole
commune c'est une construction française
parce que il y a pas une agriculture il
y a plusieurs agriculture dans notre
pays vous voyez bien que celles et ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui piégés par
l'endettement piégés par l'explosion des
couts piégé par
l'agro-industrie qui fait des marges
extraordinaires piégé par le dérèglement
climatique c'est pas les mêmes que y
compris Monsieur Arnaud Rousseau patron
de la FNSEA qui vit très bien du
commerce international qui vit très bien
de
l'agro-industrie et au fond qui vit très
bien des marges de l'agroindustrie qui
se font sur le dos des petits
agriculteurs alors sur le plan politique
cette crise agricole c'est le baptême du
feu pour le nouveau Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal Gabriel tal qui hier à
l'Assemblée nationale a ciblé les
oppositions et précisément les
écologistes je le cite
il s'adressait aux écologistes vos
larmes pour nos agriculteurs ressemblent
à des larmes de crocodiles vous
présentez souvent les agriculteurs comme
des bandits des pollueurs de nos teres
des tortionnaires de nos animaux et à
chaque fois que les agriculteurs ont un
projet d'extension qui s'y oppose c'est
vous Yanni jado qu'est-ce que vous
répond à Gabriel Talan je pense que
c'est
irresponsable c'est lâche et c'est assez
minable en fait le premier ministre
visiblement continue c'est pas une
nouveauté avec ce pouvoir
malheureusement ça fait suite à d'autres
gouvernements à une totale
irresponsabilité en matière
d'agriculture encore une
fois on a des paysanes et des paysans
qui on le sait aujourd'hui le monde est
très instable tout le monde dans la
société et terrifié par l'avenir parce
qu'on voit qu'à chaque fois les droits
sociaux sont reniés on voit les guerres
on voit l'instabilité on voit les chocs
du dérèglement climatique et ben pour
les agriculturus et les agriculteurs
c'est puissance 10 dans les Pyrénées
d'où vous venez je ve dire le
dérèglement climatique c'est la
catastrophe absolue quand il fait vous
le savez bien quand il fait 40 45°grés
par canicule au niveau du sol des vignes
c'est comme si vous mettiez un coup de
chalumeau sur le raisin il y a plus
d'eau mais pour pas et donc qu'est-ce
que dit qu'est-ce que dit le Premier
ministre il dit mais tout ça c'est la
faute des écologistes tout ça c'est la
responsabilité il trouve un bou
hémissère plutôt que de travailler à des
solution les agriculteurs veulent des
mégabacin les agriculteurs veulent
utiliser euh plus de produits
phytosanitaires pour justement paser à
ce problème comment expliquez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui votre discours écologiste
ne percolle pas chez les agriculteurs
mais écoutez un je conteste ce que vous
dites parce que ça voudrait dire qu'en
fait c'est ignoré et mépriser les
milliers d'agriculteurs qui passent à
l'agroécologie qui passent au bio qui se
disent si je veux
poursuivre mon métier non seulement il
faut que j'ai un revenu et il faut
travailler sur le revenu la
Confédération paysanne a raison de dire
que c'est scandaleux quand les l'aval de
l'alimentation ne paye pas les prix au
au mieux au coup de revient c'est
scandaleux de payer en dessous du coup
de revient mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ignorer renvoyer aux
écologistes la crise agricole c'est
ignorer le débat qui doit y avoir au
sein de la profession agricole dans la
profession agricole il y en a qui jouent
des marchés internationaux et qui de
fait mais ce ce est dit sur les barrages
aujourd'hui c'est onous lesi moi moi par
exemple la ha des tax sur le gazol non
routier qu'il faut abandonner cette TX
le mot norme est utilisé aujourd'hui
comme un comme un gros mot vous vous
rendez compte mais la norme c'est ce qui
protège notre santé allez demander au
breton ils aimeraient bien avoir des
normes pour empêcher les algues vertes
la TA sur le Gazo non routier ce qu'il
faut revenir dessus mais voyez comment
moi on a le même débat qu'avec la taxe
carbone nous on s c'est toujours battu
contre parce pour qu'à chaque fois qu'il
y a une fiscalité écologique elle soit
reversée aux acteurs pour les aider à
faire la transition et là ce que dit la
profession agricole dans encore une fois
dans des avec des agricultrices qui sont
piégés aujourd'hui vous avez près d'un
près de deux suicides par jour vous avez
un/4 de la profession qui vit sous le
seuil de pauvreté et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait plutôt que de résoudre cette crise
là on dit c'est la faute des écologistes
encore une fois c'est minable parce que
le dérèglement climatique il est là la
raréfaction de l'eau elle est là c'est
pas en inventant de l'eau dans des
bassines alors qu'il pleut plus et qu'on
on peut plus en consommer pour
nous-mêmes qu'on va résoudre les
problèmes donc encore une fois juste
là-dessus il y a le sujet de la
politique agricole commune si le
gouvernement doit agir c'est un
contraindre les marges de la
transformation et de l'agroindustrie
elles ont explosé au détriment des
paysans de les aides doivent aller
aux unités de production c'est plus vous
avez de salariés plus vous touchez plus
vous respectez la nature plus vous
touchez c'est le contraire
aujourd'hui